Abraham a 17 ans ses parents comme ceux
de la future mariée sont vendeur
ambulant et de sac d'IGN dans la cuisine
vous les mettez tout en haut ok cela
fait un an qu'ils économisent pour payer
ses no elles ont coûté 30000 € pour un
gitan même pauvre un mariage doit être
spectaculaire même s'ils ont investi une
grande partie de leurs économies ils
n'ont pas pu s'offrir de traiteur alors
c'est toute la famille qui se met au
fourneau de groses quantité sont à
prévoir car chez les G il n'y a pas
d'itation tout le monde pe venir à la
fête bon amis al merci Enoc merci d'être
là mon frérot ça c'est c'est mon frère
ça ça va mon frérot d'amour impeccable
tu vas bien tester là cet été là sur tes
PMP même l'été vasy autour de la table
bon par contre tu serasvec Castali tu
comprendras rien mais tu fa comprendre
je crois qu'il il y aura plein de monde
tu plein d'animateur t'inquiète pas
c'est très sympa et puis moi je serai
pas là et tu pourras tu vas
kiffer on vaevoir des images de ce
reportage là la première chose qui a
choqué les téléspectateurs c'est quand
on découvre les deux jeunes mariés parce
qu'il s'agit en réalité de deux très
jeunes mariés regardez elle s'appelle
Nera elle n'a que 15 ans elle est encore
au collège c'est adolescente quittera sa
famille ce soir les deux adolescents se
connaissent depuis qu'ils sont nés
Abraham a demandé Nera en mariage il y a
un an elle avait alors 14
ans très très bon alors euh est-ce que
est-ce que ça choque quelqu'un ici oui
oui g ver là franchement euh sais se
marie entre 14 et 16 ans souvent là
c'est 15 ans mais est-ce qu'à 15 ans on
a son libre arbitre est-ce que ce ne
sont pas les familles qui vont orienter
le mariage moi ça ça me perturbe
grandement je vous le dis sincèrement
alors moi je te dou déjà souvent choqué
mais alors je vais te dire ça on a pris
pareil un extrait ù où ça c'est fini he
on est en 2023 plus personne se marie à
15 et a 16 ans aujourd'hui elle se mari
plus tard ell prennent le temps on a
pris un extrait c'estàdire enfin on a
pris dans cette émission on voit qu'elle
a 15 ans ça arrive encore mais il y a
pas longtemps en France encore ça arrivé
c'està dire qu' sachant que toute notre
vie nous les G on a été mis de côté ça
veut dire que en vérité on est dans les
temps là tu vois on arrive gentim le
mariage aussi jeune ça te choque toi bah
en fait c à l'ancienne les mariages
comme ça je pense c'est c'était céit à
l'ancienne qu'on se qu'on se mariait tôt
ça te dérange
toi un peu ouais c'est ouais un peu elle
a pas peur de faire bouger les lignes à
Nissa dans ce qu'elle
dit vra après c'est compliqué c'est
c'est leur coutume aussi donc on peut
pas trop juger non plus plus quoi elle
veut casser les codes mais comme elle
dit c'est compliqué c'est leur coutume
bravoï non mais la coutume ne justifie
pas tout là il s'agit quand même de
jeunes gens qui sont mineurs on apprend
également dans le reportage que déjà
même lorsqu'ils sont encore plus petits
c'est-à-dire 11 ans 12 ans on ils se
promettent l'un l'autre donc moi là là
moi pardon mais ça me pose un souci
effectivement oui c'est des bêtises
c'est des conneries ça veut dire c'est
une VO qui l'a dit ça encore tu as vu
fake attends c'est c'est conneries à 12
ans 11 ans attendez moi écoute je sais
pas ma fille elle a 15 ans elle est
encore avé en en pyjama Cendrillon je
veux dire elle pense pas à se marier
elle pense juste avoir des nouvelles
chaussures où elle a pris marque ENF
jeuxille non mais en vérité il pense pas
à se marie c'est fini c'est une époque
là on a pris c'est toujours pareil tu as
vu on prend toujours en plus je peux
plus me les dit je peux plus me les voir
tu les é vén enquête capit mon frère
c'est que toujours à charge ça veut dire
ils te font un truc ils te mettent une
voix le mec qui va chercher c'estis un
paquet de cigarette ou une connerie on
dit sûrement avec l'argent du crime non
mon frère la B elle te dit tout mon
frère te dit la réponse elle te dit la
question elle te c'est abusé ENF pour
vous ça veut dire que c'est pas une
réalité ce qui se passe en Andalousie
mais jamais de la vie ça arrive alors
bien sûr que ça peut arriver mais c'est
comme tout hier on a vu les mecs cabrés
bien sûr que ça arrive mais c'est pas
partout arrêtez les gars on fait une
généralité de tout attends ch et vous ça
vous choque les le peu de fois où ça
arrive écoutez F SIME vous savez chez
nous il c'est alors c'est très rare les
divorce pas par obligation parce que il
y a plein de divorce il ça arrive chez
nous aussi mais souvent les gens vous
savez quand vous savez c'est c'est quoi
quand on courtise une fille vous savez
que souvent on pose pas la question
c'est des mois et des mois de travail au
corps on Dr la fille où il se passe rien
on se voit en cachette c'est un petit
bisou c'est des trucs qui sont
merveilleux c'est romantique au possible
et quand il se mari bah il se mari pour
de vrai vous voyez ce que je veux dire
ça ve dire c'est vraiment des mariages
d'amour et c'est c'est oui mais vous
est-ce que ça vous choque à 12 ans par
exemple qu'une jeune fille soit Pr
l'un des extraits et l'une des
traditions les plus polémiques c'est la
cérémonie du mouchoir c'est un passage
obligatoire pour la marier sa virginité
est vérifié avec un mouchoir regardez
c'est l'extrait qui a fait le plus
polémique la cérémonie du mouchoir une
tradition séculaire secrète la mariée
sera ici avec un mouchoir elle va
prouver qu'elle est vierge dès que les
petites finesses on les éduque ainsi
elles doivent donner leur
honneur alors elles font attention elles
ne peuvent pas avoir de petits copain
leur mariage si Néa n'est pas vierge
elle fera la honte de sa famille et ne
pourra pas se marier les hommes eux
n'ont rien à prouvver du tout ils
attendent dehors la vérification de
l'imen ne dure que quelques
minutes Néa est maintenant
officiellement
marié ce mouchoir appartient maintenant
à la belle- mère de Néa al euh est-ce
que ça ça vous choque ah oui oui c'est
illégal il faut le rappeler en France
tout acte qui tente à attester de la
virginité d'une personne à forcierie
mineur c'est un an de prison et 30000 €
d'Amand donc ça c'est illégal en France
et moi ça me choque parce que en fait
c'est privé cette jeune femme de son
libre arbitre c'estàd qu'elle est
promise vierge là c'est presque je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez mais elle est
presque forcée d'être vierge elle n'est
plus libre d'elle-même écoutez il y a
plus de mariage où justement il y a pas
de cérémonie du mouchoir ça arrive bien
sûr ça arrive encore alors mais bon non
mais ça ça c'est vraiment ça c'est une
tradition a qui le font pas c'est une
tradition bien sûr que c'est une
tradition oui la plupart le font mais ce
que je veux te dire c'est que elle est
pas forcée ça veut dire que elle est
obligée elle peut choisir de pas voir le
mouchoir elle peut le choisir de dire
écoute moi je fais pas j'ai un cousin s
Maré j'ai un cousin qui s'est marié la
semaine dernière ils ont pas fait
la on
reste bien pardon mais effectivement
elle est ouisous
par la communauté qui dit évidemment si
elle le refuse ce sera un souci paril y
aura forcment une susp et donc la honte
sur le reste de la famille et cetera
donc même si officiellement elle est
consentante fondamentalement elle est
elle se sent obligée contrainte de le
faire donc voilà donc ça pose problème
évidemment que ça pose problèmeout savez
que ça été imposé à did avant le mariage
ah oua ouais ça les G
alorsz défendreend
inéress oui c'est dans la couronne la
couronne anglaise on a imposé à l lors
du mariage du prince Charles l'
certificat de virginité elle a dû voir
le le gynécologue s'appelle docteur
Pinker je voulais être précis dans cette
histoire et il a prouvé donc qu'elle
était vierge elle a pu époser Charles
alors là ch
personne très Cho ici mais attendez je
vous le dis parce que ici c'est c'est
illégal l'Assemblée nationale a voté le
projet de loi sur le séparatisme qui
vise notamment à renforcer les mesures
de dignité humaine en interdisant les
tests de virginité et en surant cons des
ép ils on été plus loin enant tout
certificat de virginité les médecs qui
les dév peuvent être sannés
regardez ces certificats censé prouver
la virginité d'une femme sont une
violation des droits fondamentaux le
projet de loi contre les séparatismes va
permettre de les interdire et de
sanctionner les médecins qui les
rédigent d'une peine d'un an de prison
et 15000 € d'Amand il faut que la France
arrête ces gestes qui sont humiliants
pour les femmes qui ne sont jamais
demandé par elle qui sont demandés par
la famille c'est une excellente mesure
et le collège national des gynécologues
applaudit des deux mains alors euh oui
ça pourrait moi j'imagine ça peut être
considéré comme une preuve d'amour de
savoir que sa future marié s'est réservé
pour son future mari le problème c'est
le problème c'est que c'est pas
réciproque c'estd que lui on lui deme
pas le pro de virginité il a pu faire
toutes les conneries qu'il voulait avant
s'il le veut et après c'est c'est
surtout le début d'une série de de
gestes matcho où l'homme est le roi
absolu et la femme est à son service
tout le temps
ça dire tu peux plus Ren fairere tout de
suite vérité ça veut direaujourd'hui tu
peux même plus être virile mon AM non
mais il
pas l'homme gant ne fait rien c'est qu'à
la maison c'est la femme qui fait à
manger qui
fait faut qu' rentre mais arrêtez les
amis on est on v dans le même
pays mais attends les mecs qui
travaillent toute la journée il rent sa
femme elle est resté c'est un travail de
s'occuper moi vous savez quoi si ma
femme voulait changer le travail avec
moi jamais de ma vie je elle a un
travail de fou à la maison ma femme mais
j'en ai quatre la tomberé le dernier en
plus un psychopathe c'est compliqué non
la vérité c'est mais ce que je veux dire
chacun chacun ch chacun fait comme il
veut bordel aujourd'hui tu sais on
dirait que tu as plus le droit tu as
plus le droit que ta femme elle reste à
la maison et que toi tu vas travailler
ou que elleelle va on dirait que tout tu
jugé c'est pas pareil le fait qu'elle
mange une fois que les hommes ont les
femmes mangent une fois que les hommes
ont mangé mangent après c'est mais ça
aussi ça arrive ça arrive il des fois ça
arrive c'est pas mais sauf que
pardonnez-moi mais le le plus
g pardon parce qu'après chacun fait
comme il veut che lui s en couple si la
femme elle envie de rester d'élever les
enfants j'ai pas à juger ça en revanche
effectivement le certificat de virginité
le monsieur la responsable de tous les
gynécos en France disait que il y avait
une pression de la famille et que la
femme la jeune fille quand elle arrivait
finalement elle famille bien sûr mais ça
veut dire est-ce que si elle elle envie
donc ça vous le condamnez vous à titre
personnel si si la pression bien sûr ça
veut dire que pour vous il y a des fois
où il n'y a pas de pression mais bien
sûr il y a des filles qui veulent com à
15 ans une fille peut si depuis toute
petite elle a été éduquée comme ça
comment elle peut avoir son libre
arbitre pour dire ben moi je vais être
vierge et c'est comme ça vous pensez pas
qu'elle est malgré tout sous pression et
sous emprise après je suis pas dans sa
tête je suis pas la tête des gens pe on
n'est pas dans la tête des gens mais en
vérité vous savez quand c'est une
coutume c'est comme ça aujourd'hui en
France il y a plus de coutume personne
perd ses traditions il y a plus aucune
tradition en France a des G qui disent
pourquoi ils se mettent des traditions
des autres il y a plein de gens qui
disent ça
surors qu'est-ce que vous répondz à ça
TI qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
çaégalité illégalité C à partir du
moment où il y a eu la loi il y a plein
de gens qui disent pourquoi de quoi il
se met trad mais qu'est-ce que vous
répond alors je je vais vous répondre
très
franchement chez les musulmans aussi il
y a des traditions qui parfois pèsent et
cetera donc je vous le dis très
franchement toi tu as des traditions qui
te pèisent oui chez les musulmans il y a
des traditions et la musulmans toi
maintenant tu lui bien sûr oui je vous
le dis et la virginité peut être exigée
aussi
c'était cé c'était le déshonneur c'est
une femme vousz tradition chez vous
c'est avant de se marier une semaine
avant vous faites l'enterrement de V
garçon avant de vous promettre en
mariage pour la vie vous allez vous
frotter contre un ou contre pas
moiou ça veut dire ça peut me choquer
aussi tu vas dire à ta femme tu vas te
marier pour toute la
vie mon frère on n pas des Bonobo c'est
bon alors Géraldine tu disis un truc non
mais sauf que c'est
fa lo la lo on est dans un pays des
loisors qu' sont pas bonnes maisf qu'il
faut soumettre au lo de not P ouais mais
les lois pays lois qui datent depuis
Napoléon il faut les remettre auout du
j elle vise à protéger à protéger les
femmes et et les hommes d'ailleurs
Napoléon on a la chance d'avoir l'iglon
ici
dan tu dis moi je suis la première
pourtant à vouloir respecter les
traditions mais là d'abord c'est illégal
et puis il y a quand même un problème
c'est que évidemment ils sont en Espagne
je rappelle que
Espagne
pas l'époque a changé et les jeunes
filles malheureusement n'arrivent pas
toujours vierge et maintenant il y a
quelque chose qui
[Musique]
s les temps ont changé et il y a quand
même quelque chose qui s'appelle leido
racommodage c'estàdire en
fait c'estàd qu'en fait
sel et il y a tout comme ça coûte très
cher quelquefis ell font appel des gens
qui ne sont pas et ça fait des inctions
et tout ça donc c'est un problème
ant
trad
bus il y a des inctions son contraire ça
veut dire qu'on veut tout sexualis
auourd'hi a le tout et son contraire ça
veut dire que on veut tout sexualiser
aujourd'hui ça veut dire on ve les
sexualiser à l'école primaire moi je
vous dire ma petite fille elle a 15 ans
elle regarde encore blancheige
Mach laissz grandir vous savez moi une
fille à 18 ans c'est encore bébé vous
savez quoi son père moi ma fille a 18
ans si elle avait un téléphone elle en a
pas que Dieu la bénisse mais si elle en
avait un je lui enlève son téléphone
elle va pleurer dans sa chambre et quand
elle va se marier c'est un bébé encore
même à 18 ans c'est un bébé vous voyez
ce que je veux dire laissez-les grandir
laissez-les prendre le temps aujourd'hui
on dirait qu'à 14 ans il faut applaudir
mais je sais pas moi qu'est-ce qu'on
veut nos enfants qu'est-ce qu'on veut
faire nos enfants bordel et quand elle
va se marier vous vous imposerez un
certificat de virginité moi sa tradition
je pense qu'il va le fairez
je je vais vous dire la vérité le faire
je voudrais lui faire un beau mariage un
mariage de princesse frè comme t les
bien sûr mais quel père tu vas faire la
cérémonie du mouchoir non pas la
cérémonie du mouchoir elle fera ce
qu'elle veut en fait si elle décide de
le faire elle fera mais je vais vous
expliquer un
truc elle fera 18 ans c'estgal après je
sais pas je vais vous dire moi ce que je
veux moi je veux pour ma fille qu'elle
soit qu'elle aime son mari je veut les
plus belles choses du monde elle fera ce
qu'elle veut du moment que c'est qu'elle
est heureuse bordel je rien de plus
alors je la protège je la protège
énormément parce que j'ai peur ou j'ai
peur vous savez qu'il y a combien de
filles si on faisait un sondage il y a
combien de filles qui ont couché avec
quelqu'un la première fois elles avaient
même pas envie elles l'ont fait parce
que la copine l'a fait ou parce que vous
savez c'est limite un viol à chaque fois
c'estàd
que je vous expliquer par qu'elle ose
pas dire
non consentement un viol une agression
sexuelle s'il y a un consentement ce
n'est ni un VI AG des fois quand tu
Sessé des fois tu as pas envie de faire
quelque chose mais tu te sens obligé de
faire retournez pas la charge
accusatoire parce que effectivement il y
y a des jeunes femmes qui peuvent après
coup se dire à ma première fois était
pas formidable mais mais elle l'a
souhaité et on peut pas le comparer à un
viol parce que c'est alors peut-être que
j'ai mal comparé les mots peut-être
voilà peut-être que le mot est peut- pas
bon viol mais ce que je veux dire
laissez- les grandir bordel laissez- les
grandir laissz les on les laisse grandir
je trouve pour une femme pour un homme
de se préserver avant le mariage et là
où il a raison c'est que dans notre non
mais c'est vrai bah parce que on a
grandi dans une société où moi par on
m'a pas dit que faire l'amour c'était
quelque chose de de d'important qu'il
faut pas faire avec n'importe qui et
cetera et moi je trouve ça beau après
c'est vrai que la cérémonie du mouchoir
elle est extrêmement violente et que la
la jeune fille qu'on voit et il y a
d'autres reportages qui l'ont fait aussi
on a l'impression qu'elles sont au bout
de leur vie parce que c'est devant des
dizaines de personnes et cetera donc
est-ce que ça peut pas on peut pas faire
évoluer la tradition pour que ce soit
une promesse morale et qui a pas c'est
en gros cette humiliation un peu devant
tout le monde avec des jeunes femmes qui
sont pas très contentes ça va lui il est
pas chef vous l'avez vu moi je suis le
chef de rien du tout plus expliquer je
parle que à mon nom d'ailleurs quand je
parle quand vous la voyez pleurer là
vous croyez qu'elle pleure par
souffrance elle pleure parce qu'elle est
émue elle est vécu avec son papa et sa
maman et et au même titre qu'une femme
de 20 ans qu'elle vous savez quand vous
allez vous marier même chez vous tu
prends une femme de même de 20 ans 25
ans et tout dès que pas pourquoi tu
regardes Daniel j'ai dit 22 ans un ou de
ans près tu l' pas ex bravo et ce que je
veux te dire c'est que elle pleure aussi
tu sais dès qu'on lui passe la Ball elle
fait un bisou elle pleure elle est mue
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire alors
tu vois ça à la télé tu as l'impression
qu'elle souffre elle est heureuse d'être
là elle a fait grâce à toute sa famille
elle a décidé d'être VI jusqu'au je vois
pas où où est inérét je vois même pas
pourquoi on en parle aujourd'hui parce
que c'est en Espagne en
plus et alors qu'est-ce qui peut arriver
qu'est-ce qui peut arriver ce jour du
mariage si la jeune femme n'est pas
vierge justement qu'est-ce qui lui
arrive ah c'est ça moi j'ai jamaisage
annulé jamais voilàage annulé mais
disnous dis-nous ça a dû arriver
francment franchement à ma connaissance
Qu'est-ce qui lui arnaiss je elle doit
quitter le l'environnement la fam jamais
de la vie alors il Anissa qui a sa
petite idée ouiissa bah je pense qu'elle
va être nié de de sa famille tout
simplement parce que c'est malade on les
aime nos enfants ça arriv alors ça veut
dire mon fils il fume de la drog je Reun
ma famille alors je l'engueule je je
suis pas content mais Reun la fam fa
juste bouger les lignes oui oui boug
dans le reportage en tout cas on
expliqueeffectivement il y a une dame
qui dit si effectivement elle ne elle
elle ne devait pas être vierge ce serait
la honte sur la famille on imagine les
conséquen ça te choque ça non ça j pas
mais c'est très fort ce qui dire en fait
elle veut divertir toute la
famille pu qu'elle fait tomber les
puissants et pourquoi les filles doivent
être vierges et pas les garçons mais
comment tu le prouves non mais comp moi
je vois tout suite pas dit ça mais
champion du
mondeêtre moral ça veut dire que la
fille c'est pas on n
pas a raison sur un truc le garçon peut
dire voilà moi aussi c'est la première
fois sans vérifie ah oui un contrat
moral
non pour la virginité d'un fille est
plus important que virginité d'un gar
parce que les femmes sont très
importantes chez nous contrairement à
tout ce qu'on peut penser c'est parce
que vous sacralisez la femme soit vierge
et que vous voulez qu'on lui impose un
mariage à 11 ans à 12 ans à 15 ans non
attendez ça c'est vous qui le
dites V saral si on croyait les
reportages je dis voilà on serait pas là
je suis d'accord avec un reportage ça
fait dire ce que que tu veux
a donc voilà donc merci donc je vais te
dire avec un reportage tu fais dire
n'importe quoi avec un reportage peux
dire que Bernard Montiel a trois
couilles merci alors ils font ensuite la
fête jusqu'à très tard ils sont fers et
ils ront jusqu'à s'installer ensemble
regardez en signe de respect son père et
son grand-père laïent sur leur
[Applaudissements]
dos il est près de 5h du matin na peut
enfin
souffler
Abraham lui est félicité par les hommes
pour la virginité de sa
femme on sera toujours ensemble c'est
comme ça chez
nous chez les gitans espagnols plus
qu'ailleurs les règles sont stricte le
divorce est interdit dès la fin de la
cérémonie le couple s'installera dans un
appartement dans le quartier de leur
enfance fou c'est fou c'est c'est fou le
divorce interdit ils ont dit divorce
interdit mais pareil c'est la voix off
mais vous l'écoutez mais la voix off
elle fait dire vous savez quoi la VO
elle peut dire n'importe quoi moi je
fais un reportage pour capital je
parle venu non mais ça c'est encore un
autre non mais tu étais pas venu j'étais
pas venu à l'époque ou écoutez je vous
jure que je vous mens pas et on peut le
vérifier on prend un hangar et moi je
dis au mec de caméraman je veux pas
qu'on tu as vu je suis un peu connu je
veux pas que on puisse vérifier enfin
situer le lieu de là où il est le le
hangar sa ce qu'il a dit la VO ils ont
ouvert un hangar
comme si on avait s un truc- qu'il ont
dit dit qu'on av un truc alors que c'est
le garage de mon Cousinou juste pas sair
où il
était VO tect second merci de participer
àémission hore votre
cach oui 7% non à
33%